New Hampshire resident Jonathan blitz
says he leans Republican Sue and Lee
will Borgnine Democrat but like many
voters in the state they don't belong to
a political party this is serious stuff
and we need to change the direction of
the country right now they were among
hundreds of voters who lined up to see
Democrat Pete Buddha judge in a school
auditorium I'm balancing between Pete
and Bernie right now although I do like
a man clove a char to a little bit with
no clear front-runner for the Democratic
presidential nomination these
independent voters are in high demand
particularly by middle-of-the-road
candidates like Buddha judge when you're
coming up here to run for president
you're not just appealing to the members
of your own party but you're also trying
to reach those folks in the middle who
might vote for your party but not want
to identify with it maybe are not as
ideological maybe a bit more pragmatic
minded 42% of the electorate here has no
party affiliation and unlike voters in
other states independence in New
Hampshire can vote in either primary
democrat or republican that's led to
some surprise finishes in the past in
2016 Bernie Sanders who comes from the
neighboring state of Vermont beat party
favorite Hillary Clinton here by more
than 20 percent with his strong base of
support he could win the primary again
in 2020 but this year is like none other
dude at the large field of Democrats and
a president who's loved by his base but
despised by the left so if you're a
voter who doesn't like Bernie Sanders
you're not just thinking which candidate
do I like more than Bernie Sanders
you're trying to think which candidate
who is not Bernie Sanders do I like can
I support who I think has the best shot
of beating him it's a job these voters
take seriously we're still debating but
I think he would be an excellent choice
for the President of the United States
I'm excited about - what I've heard now
you 180 or more I like what I hear
sounds like you're still not decided
though
close but I'm not making the outcome
hard to predict Kristen salumi al
Jazeera Nashua New Hampshire